موجز والاخبار اهلا بكم قال الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب ان اداره
بايدن ابلغت محاميه بتوجيه اتهامات ضده
على خلفيه قضيه احتفاضه بوثائق سريه
انه جرس ادعائه للمثول امام المحكمه
الفيدراليه في مدينه ميامي يوم الثلاثاء
المقبل وصفت ترامب لائحه الاتهام بانها
تدخل على اعلى المستويات الانتخابات
الرئاسيه ونقلت وسائل الاعلام امريكيه عن
مصادر مطلعه بانه تم توجيه سبع تهم لترام
من قبل هيئه محلفين كبرى
افاد مراسل الجزيره في السودان بان معارك
بالاسلحه الثقيله دارت امس بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في المنطقه الصناعيه
بالعاصمه الخرطوم وشارع الغابه وتستمر
الحرائق في اكبر منشاه للنفط والغاز جنوب
الخرطوم عقب معارك امس للسيطره على مجمع
اليرموك لصناعه الدفاعيه
في غرب السودان قال نائب رئيس التحالف
السوداني الذي يحكم ولايه غرب دارفور ان
عدد القتلى خلال الاسابيع الماضيه في
مدينه جنينه بلغ 850 شخصا اضافه الى 2000
جريح واعلنت السلطات المحليه مدينه
الجنينه في ولايه غرب دارفور منطقه منكوبا
ومعزوله عن العالم
قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ان هناك بوادر ايجابيه في
المحادثات بشان تطورات في السودان
وامكانيه التوصل لعده جديده مع اليات
مراقبه اكثر تشددا
قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني انكيف لديها
افاق جيده للغايه لتطوير برنامج الصاروخي
واوضح الوزير ان تطوير الصواريخ
الاوكرانيه يستهدف زياده مداها الى اكثر
من الف كيلو متر
اعلن وزير الدفاع الروسي عن احباط محاوله
للقوات الاوكرانيه لاختراق خطوط دفاعات
القوات الروسيه في محور زبروجيا ووصف
شويجو الهجوم بالمفاجئ وغير المسبوق
نقلت عن مصادر مطلعه ان وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه تستعد لتقديم حزمه مساعدات
جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه مليار دولار واضافت
المصادر ان الحزمه الامريكيه المقبله
تتضمن معدات لدعم الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني
قال الرئيس الامريكي انه ناقش مع رئيس
وزراء بريطانيا الدعم المشتركه لشعب
الاوكراني في مواجهه العدوان الروسي البشع
وضاف بايدن في مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع سونار
بواشنطون ان بلديهما يعملان على توفير كل
ما تحتاجه اوكرانيا لدعم جيشها
نقل صحيفه بوليتيكو عن مصادر مطلعه قولها
ان وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه يستعد لزياره
الصين خلال الاسبوع المقبل وافادت الصحيفه
ان وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ما تزال تضع
اللمسات الاخيره لتفاصيل زياره بلينكن
والتي ستكون الاولى له منذ تعيينه في
منصبه
وتاتي زياره بينما قال طوكيو ان سفينتين
صينيتين دخلتا مياه اليابان الاقليميه
وحاولت الاقتراب من قارب صيد ياباني في
بيجين حثه الخارجيه صينيه الولايات
المتحده واليابان على الالتزام بمبدا
الصين الواحده والامتناع عن اثاره التوتر
في مضيق تعبير المتحدث باسمها
كتاب الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]